gavin newsom has officially won his
recall election in california and
because elections have consequences
newsom is already using the win
california democrats are already using
the win to push for vaccine mandates at
the state level i want to focus on what
we said yes to
as a state we said yes to science we
said yes to vaccines
we said yes to ending this pandemic
we said yes to people's right to vote
without fear of
fake fraud or voter suppression
we said yes
to women's fundamental constitutional
right to decide for herself
what she does with her body and her fate
and future
we said yes to diversity
we said yes to inclusion
we said yes to pluralism
we said yes
to all those things that we hold dear as
californians and i would argue as
americans
so newsom obviously got a lot of things
wrong in that speech
most notably pluralism california did
not say yes to pluralism california said
yes to one party rule and that one party
rule
is going to mean vaccine mandates he's
right about that it's going to mean more
terrible government elections have
consequences a regime has consequences
our ruling class has consequences for us
elections be damned
i don't think the american people are
going to like the consequences in the
long term i'm michael knowles the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from michelle glass
who says there were people who went to
vote only to find out that they had
already voted when they didn't how can
that be a good system
it is a good system
for the ruling class and not just in
california i'm not saying the california
recall election was rigged i strongly
suspect well i know it was rigged it
certainly was rigged but i i don't think
that the outcome was contrary to the
will of the people i strongly suspect
just looking at the way voter
registration works in california i
strongly suspect gavin newsom would have
survived the election recall
even if there weren't widespread mail-in
votes and all the problems with those
mail-in votes and people showing up to
the polls to find out they already voted
even without all of the the fraud that
you see there but but throughout the
rest of the country who does this system
serve the system serves
the entrenched ruling class so it does
work it doesn't work in the traditional
american constitutional order way but it
sure works well for the ruling class
you know
when you want a little autonomy when you
want to do things for yourself and not
just be told what to do by everyone else
i strongly recommend you check out rock
auto listen i'm not the most handy man
in the world okay i am not telling any
tales out of school here and yet
when i want
an auto part
even i can navigate
rockauto.com's amazing catalog it's that
simple it's that straightforward and
it's so much better than going to that
brick and mortar store where you get
peppered with a thousand questions and
you don't know the answer to them and is
your is it is your car a gt or an xb or
no i don't know what my car is like a
gray sedan that's what my car is and uh
you know okay well it's and it's a 2010
and okay and then you go out they go
online they don't have the part you have
to wait you have to pay twice as much
don't do that skip that go to
rockauto.com you get the best prices
they're reliably low there's no gimmicks
it's not this price on tuesday morning
and this price on wednesday afternoon
it's a family company it has they've
been in the business serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years go to
rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck and then write knowles
k-w-l-e-s and their how did you hear
about us box so they know that we sent
you newsom declares victory
larry elder very gracious in his defeat
says we lost the battle but we will win
the war conservatives will come back and
we will fight and i really feel for
california conservatives i'm one of
those who fled some of my
many friends who were left in california
were texting me despairingly some of my
well-known friends i'm not going to name
dave rubin's name but you know some
people were really
upset by what happened in california
it's time to free flee to freer pastures
i think i i don't think that you are
going to see
anything resembling conservative
government in california anytime soon
and it's it's not as though
the
democrat rulers in california are taking
this recall as a reprimand and saying oh
gosh all right we better moderate
clearly the people don't like how far
we've gone no they're taking it as a
mandate to go even further notably on
the point of vaccine mandates so l.a
county announced yesterday
they're going to
move forward with a vaccine mandate
you're going to need to show proof of
vaccination or a negative covid test for
a ton of events for indoor bars wineries
breweries nightclubs and lounges
they'll also require it for big outdoor
events like dodgers games ram games
chargers games
this according to the county public
health director
now what they're going to say is it's
not a vaccine mandate you see because
you can just show a negative covid test
okay i guess that's better
than not having that option but negative
coveted tests are expensive
you're gonna have to pay whatever 20 to
30 to 40 50 bucks
every time you want to get one of these
tests
for the app at home rapid test for
instance
are you going to be able to do that
once a week twice a week are you going
to be able to do that for your entire
family no they're just going to bleed
these people dry and they're going to
impel them to get the vaccine
the irony of course with this is that
while we
hear left-wing demagogues decry the
vaccine hesitancy
among the trump supporter murderers
they're compromising public health of
course the original vaccine hesitancy
came from the libs and by the way i'm
not just pointing out that for instance
black people are
disproportionately likely not to want to
get the vaccine and black people are
disproportionately likely to vote for
democrats that's not even the point i'm
making when i say the vaccine hesitancy
came from the libs i'm saying it came
from
joe biden saying it came from kamala
harris as the rnc reminds us in a lovely
little montage i think it's going to be
a very skeptical american public about
taking the vaccine and they should be we
can't trust the president
and take his word and take a vaccine
that might cause harm to us if and when
the vaccine comes it's not likely to go
through all the tests that needs to be
ended trials that are needed to be done
let's just say there's a vaccine that is
approved and even distributed before the
election
would you get it
well i think that's going to be an issue
for all of us when we finally do god
willing get a vaccine who's going to
take the shot
who's going to take the shot we will
need to have access
to the vaccine results so we can make
our independent assessment to make sure
that donald trump's fingerprints are not
on it you can be the first one to say
put me sign me up
they now say it's okay is the vaccine
safe
frankly i'm not going to trust the
federal government's opinion
and i wouldn't recommend to new yorkers
based on the federal government's
opinion
i would not recommend that you take the
federally approved vaccine
says the now former governor andrew
cuomo who is the toast of the town
remember we were all cuomosexuals he won
an emmy
he was pushing vaccine hesitancy joe
biden not just the disgraced former
democrat politicians joe biden
the current president of the united
states i'm not sure he knows that but i
guess he's the current president
he was saying who's gonna take the
vaccine
who's gonna take it who's gonna joe
you're gonna take okay i'll take the
vaccine come over here joe i'll give you
a chocolate chocolate chip ice cream if
you take the vaccine the hypocrisy is
obvious but we forget about this because
all of this so-called vaccine hesitancy
from the libs was memory hold so now
we're told that it's only the
intransigent maga people and if you
don't take the shot or you have any
skepticism of this hastily developed
drug to treat a condition that for most
people does not pose a particularly
grave threat
with effectiveness that is seriously in
doubt
you
are a killer
fortunately some people at the
individual citizen level are sensible
jim brewer a comedian
of
i've been watching jim brewer for many
many years
he came out and he said that he is not
going to play at venues that mandate the
vaccine take a listen two quick updates
on shows
that you may think you may
be getting tickets to or you already
have tickets to
um
the wellmont theater
new jersey
not doing it um also
the
um
that's gonna be december 3rd
also the royal oak theater in michigan
uh due to the segregation
of them forcing
people to show up with vaccination to
prove you're vaccinated
to prove that you've had a shot i am
absolutely not doing those shows
i know i'm going to sacrifice a lot of
money
but i'm not going to be enslaved
by this system
or by money
my man love that that's great the only
way that we're going to fight back
against these sorts of things is if
people in prominent positions take a
stand and that can be in the private
sector or it can be in the public sector
which we'll get to in a second it can be
a political leader or it can be a
comedian an snl comedian who's playing a
show or it can be eric clapton who's who
says that he's not going to play to
vaccine mandate venues
great great stuff notice what he says
here i think the wright can learn a lot
from this i know i'm going to sacrifice
a lot of money but i'm not going to be
enslaved to the system or
to money
it's amazing that we on the right
conservatives we talk a good game on
virtue
on religion on morality on defending our
way of life but for the past 20 30 years
at least
we seem to be slaves to money
on the one hand conservatives go out
there and they say we need to protect
our traditions and our family values and
our way of life and also we need to
support
free trade and and creative destruction
and outsourcing and gdp at all costs
we've become [ __ ]
to
slight upticks in gdp we've become
[ __ ] for tax cuts
we have become
even on the right forget about the left
for a second even on the right
slaves to the system and to money and i
think what you're seeing in the past few
years at least certainly since the trump
phenomenon it's funny that it took a
billionaire to show us this
is republicans and conservatives
breaking away
from that
slavery that slavery to a system of
money recognizing you know even if
i don't know mass migration increases
gdp a little bit that's not good we
don't want that that's not good for our
country even if outsourcing all of our
stuff all of our jobs to china and
buying all outsourcing all of our
manufacturing to china buying all their
cheap trash even if that increases gdp a
little we're not going to be slaves to a
system of money even if covid vaccine
mandates increases gdp a little bit
even if it gets the economy going again
we are not going to be slaves to money
when you want to save a little bit of
money and protect yourself i strongly
recommend you check out
ring ring alarm equals peace of mind
if you're watching this show right now
you'll notice i am in a hotel room
sometimes i am on the road i really like
to know that my sweet little wife and
cute little baby are safe
ring
allows me to have that kind of peace of
mind it is a state-of-the-art security
system obviously you've heard about the
the ring video doorbells where you can
see and speak to whoever's at your door
from wherever you are you keep an eye on
every corner of your house keep it all
together in one simple app and security
system ring alarm head on over there
right now go to ring.com knowles for a
special offer on a ring alarm security
kit today start building that ring of
security around your home have a system
that is right for you up and running in
minutes ring.com knowles that is
ring.com
knowles right now i have given this out
to friends of mine i have made this a
housewarming present in part because
it's not particularly expensive so they
get a great gift and you don't have to
spend a lot of money
do yourself a favor protect your home
and your family ring.com knowles
you're seeing individuals right now
pushing back against the vaccine
mandates and you're seeing individual
performers like jim brewer or eric
clapton and you're seeing it from
individual companies like us at the
daily wire joe biden comes out and
forces a vaccine mandate
through this bizarre channel of the
administrative agencies and osha i
actually talk about that with senator
cruz on an upcoming episode of our
podcast verdict the constitutionality
how that works but you're seeing
pushback from companies daily wire says
no we're not doing it you can sue us if
you want see in court but we're just not
going to enforce that
that's all good
but it's got to be backed up with
political support as well
you're seeing that right now from the
riverside county sheriff in california
riverside county sheriff says quote
over the past couple weeks the idea of
forced vaccination has caused much
concern across the entire country i will
not enforce the vaccine mandate on
sheriff's department employees the
government has no ability and no
authority to mandate your health choices
as your sheriff i have an obligation to
guard your liberty and freedom so he's
saying specifically what i am being told
to do is to vax all my employees at the
sheriff's office i'm not going to do
that he also has a law enforcement
authority so inasmuch as the sheriff's
office is going to be involved in
enforcing the vaccine mandate broadly it
seems quite clear to me that he's not
going to do that
that's good stuff
that's what we need more of
and that is what conservatives have
missed in the past few decades while we
have just mindlessly repeated a
statement that is true but not adequate
which is politics is downstream of
culture
yes the breitbart maxim is true in as
much as the movies matter and the
culture matters and we got to shape the
culture but it's false if you believe it
to be
exclusively true because it's also true
that politics influences culture it's
also true that government
influences culture and i i think a lot
of republican politicians have
mindlessly pushed the the breitbart
maxim politics is downstream of culture
because they don't want to do their jobs
so they want to say no the government
never has any role to do anything it's
all got to be at the cultural level
nobody you have to do your jobs too if
the vaccine mandate is going to be
pushed by radical leftist politicians
then we need the vaccine mandate to be
opposed by the politicians that we
conservatives elect you've got to do
your job too there's nothing wrong with
using the government wielding government
power to stop this encroachment on our
liberties and traditions and way of life
whether that encroachment is coming from
the federal government or whether that
encroachment is coming from
google we're glad to see that sheriff's
office pushing back i think a lot of
other sheriff's office sheriff's offices
should be pushing back and i think
basically all the conservative
politicians we elect and judges that we
get in there should be pushing back as
well
use the politics that's what it's there
for there's a big divide that we're
seeing in this country right now and a
lot of people are waking up to the fact
that the divide is not
sexual as the left would tell us the
divide is not racial
as the left would tell us the divide is
not even partisan
i don't even think the divide is
republicans versus democrats in many way
what we've seen in the past few years is
that there's a kind of unit party
there's just this blob and there's it's
mostly run by democrats but there are a
few court jester republicans there whose
job it is to provide the appearance of
opposition but really they're just
they're just gestures they just really
exist to prop up that establishment and
do you know who showed this to us
nicki minaj nick i didn't see that one
coming okay i wouldn't have put my money
on that on that bet
but she showed us this she got into a
fight
uh yesterday or two days ago with joy
reid joy reid is
ostensibly this left wing woman on msnbc
and nicki minaj i think is left-wing
maybe not it's very unclear what her
politics are now nicki minaj comes out
and says look mask up follow some
guidelines but make your own healthcare
decisions don't don't take that shot and
think that there are no
concerns whatsoever and then she told
this story about a friend of hers who
had some health problems apparently from
from the vaccine and she says you know
just
do your own research make your own
decisions enjoy reid the
putative radical comes out and says no
don't do that don't do your own research
take the shot do what fauci says and
nicki minaj comes back to her and says
you're just a chill you're just a total
shill for the white man is what the
words of nicki minaj but i think what
she was implying is you're a show for
the establishment you're a shill for the
ruling class how you're telling people
they can't use their own minds so then
to make this situation even more
politically complicated
tucker carlson
on his
very conservative tv show came out and
defended nicki minaj
and nicki minaj
reposted that to her twitter account
with a bullseye take a listen to
tucker's monologue it's nicki minaj's
cousin's friend's testicles who are
swollen from taking the facts that's the
claim
but it's not anything to do with the
physical effect of the vaccine that
makes our political class mad it's the
last part of nicki minaj's tweet that
enrages them the part where she says you
should prey on it make the decision
yourself
like a free human being and quote don't
be bullied
so our media and public health officials
didn't like this because they make their
livings bullying people so they couldn't
let it stand
so
tucker gives as as always a terrific
little monologue and nicki minaj reposts
that with a bullseye emoji so you've now
got this major
pop star who
we all assumed was on the left
who is tweeting even about how she
doesn't like the white man that much and
how you know she's upset that a black
woman like joy reid would go along with
the white man who's not even usually a
white man but he's the ruling class and
then she's posting this
what we're told is this hetero
patriarchal you know
imperial hegemonic sort of tucker
carlson she's posting him and saying
that guy's got it exactly right and what
what is the criticism from everyone in
the ruling class on tucker
tucker is a populist tucker doesn't fit
neatly forget that he he disregards and
contradicts a leftist orthodoxy but he
doesn't even fit neatly on the right
he's not a usual republican he's
something different he's a terrible
white nationalist he's that's the phrase
they use now when they really want to
shut somebody up on the right but what
tucker is is he's just not going to play
along with the preset
ridiculous caricatures of our politics
of the last 20 years
which is they're supposed to be
the leftist
radical and then there's the right
winger who really he's just a
libertarian or something he just cares
about tax cuts and then there's kind of
the liberal ruling class and we see this
all play out and then nothing really
changes
and tucker comes in and he says no
no i don't think so i think it's it's
less about this pretend republican
democrat left right divide i think it's
more about the people versus the ruling
class
and nicki minaj agrees you see this with
aoc aoc proved this too from from the
other side of the play acting aoc is not
the pretend
right winger you know
libertarian dork of the last 20 years
aoc is the socialist
dork of that we that we also see play
out she shows up to the met gala and
she's wearing tax the rich on her dress
and that's right she's gonna stick it to
the man
who are all at this gal and they're all
her friends and they're all celebrating
her and they're all giving her magazine
covers and they're all celebrating
actually this dress in particular
there's a video that just came out of of
aoc walking out of the mat gala with her
her dress on with the dress being
carried by all of her servants
[Applause]
so you see
aoc
walking out there and she's being
followed by her
slaves
by her servants who you know they have
the servants at the met gala have to
wear masks generally and they're very
they're kind of quiet they're lifting up
her dress it says tax the rich tax the
rich so i can buy more slaves tax the
rich and then what happens all those
people out there all those people who
are
there for the ruling class or there for
the rich they say yes yes queen slay
yes you're doing it you're sure you're
showing us yes yes
it's all just a play
it's not
it's not so much even about
capitalism versus socialism that i don't
even think that's really the debate
i think it's
the the
ruling establishment versus all the
people who want to change something
about it aoc
just introduced a new bill
the bill is to extend
unemployment insurance through
2022
this will
this will increase
the amount of money that americans can
receive for just sitting home and doing
nothing and i know that that people are
going to decry this as socialism this is
socialism or communism i don't
i don't think it's really quite that
i think it's just neoliberalism i think
it's just more of the same i think this
is andrew yang kind of stuff remember
andrew yang runs for
for uh well first president then for
mayor of new york or you've actually
seen some people on the right talk about
this they floated this idea of the
universal basic income and the universal
basic income is just where zillionaire
plutocrats pay
people to go away people who are not
going to have jobs who are not going to
have meaning in their lives we're not
going to have much say in their
government they just get a check to go
away and that's called the universal
basic income and it's it's a consequence
not even really of communism it's a
consequence of neoliberalism
and aoc the supposed radical
is pushing for a modest somewhat modest
version of that now that's that's the
effect of it at least she might not be
aware that that's what she's doing but
rather than attack the establishment and
lead a revolution she is
she is propping up that establishment
and leading us down leading it down its
decadent and desiccated
course
you know
when i want to make sure that i am
in no way uh desiccated i like to have
uh good ranchers when was the last time
you think you had american meat
i know you go to the store and you see
okay oh grass fed oh it's probably it's
got to be
local meat you know from my local farm
around here
did you know that 80 percent of the
grass-fed beef in the grocery stores is
i guess it's from local farms that are
in south america they're from they're
not it's not from america which is why
my friends over at the good ranchers
have traveled the country on a mission
to help americans american ranchers with
american beef from american farms at
incredible prices for american customers
they've got excellent t-bones filets
strips i love their burgers i think
their burgers can't be beat they've got
better than organic chicken
you get the steakhouse quality you
deserve at a price you can afford go to
goodranchers.com
right now save 20 bucks or better yet
subscribe and save on each box of
mouth-watering american meats that will
show up right on schedule to your door
that is 20 bucks off and free express
shipping if you go right now to
goodranchers.com slash knowles k wlas or
use code knowles candlewlis at checkout
20 bucks off in free express shipping at
goodranchers.com
knowles you know
we are not going to comply here at the
daily wire we've made that very clear
with the new new biden mandate if you
want to help us in that fight head on
over to dailywire.com subscribe and use
code do not comply at checkout for 25
off
we are being threatened with
major major fines and consequences and
we're almost certainly going to have to
go to court for this and we're staffing
up on lawyers and it's
you don't go up against the liberal
establishment and think it's going to be
easy we never thought it was going to be
easy we really appreciate your support
so head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe use code do not comply at
checkout for 25 off also subscribe to
the morning wire great new podcast you
can go check it out on apple spotify
stitch or google play wherever you get
your podcasts leave a five-star review
if you like it we'll be right back with
a lot more
aoc pretends to be the radical working
for the people she is really nothing
more than a tool of the plutocrats you
want evidence of this she and joe biden
seem to be in agreement joe biden the
most establishmentarian politician ever
there was aoc the
supposed pretend radical they seem to
agree
aoc wears her tax the rich dress and
then what happens joe biden tweets out
it's time to tax the super wealthy and
big corporations and make them pay their
fair share in taxes aoc responds to joe
biden couldn't agree more taxing the
rich will help us expand medicare extend
child care take action on climate and so
much more we have a precious opportunity
right now in reconciliation with the
build back better act and we should use
it
so this is this is being used
to suggest by by some people on the
right naively i think that joe biden is
really a radical joe biden is a
socialist joe biden is a communist
i think it actually makes more sense in
the other direction
meaning
aoc
is the tool of the establishment joe
biden is just an empty suit he's just an
avatar of the establishment and aoc is
just a tool of that as well and
yes she openly advocates socialism well
a lot of socialism
has crept into the liberal establishment
i mean there's no question about that
the american liberals have never
apologized for their support sometimes
overt of the soviet union for their
support of
of actual communists in the country and
the lines between those things are a
little bit blurry
and
it it this has become more and more so
over time
but make no mistake
the battle between them the moderate
democrats and the radical aoc it's
mostly an illusion
they're all kind of doing the same thing
they're all kind of paddling around
their real opponent
is not
the
the the right or the left or this or
that it's it's us it's it's
ordinary american people of various
backgrounds of even various political
stripes who want to preserve a capital c
constitutional political order that
increasingly has nothing to do with the
way that we're governed
the way that we're governed increasingly
is when these
soft shoe you know
performers these politician performers
just empower the federal bureaucracy to
do whatever it wants
this is bad this is why a lot of people
are concerned about
election integrity for instance we're
concerned about election integrity
because we see our constitutional system
of government slipping away before our
very eyes
and and we can see the blob changing all
the rules on election integrity even
important rules like
minimizing mail-in votes which barack
obama himself just a few years ago said
was really important to voter integrity
even basic rules like show an id so that
you can vote you've got to show your
medical history if you want to go to a
bar these days but you don't have to
show an id and prove you are who you say
you are for this supposedly sacred act
of our supposed democracy it doesn't
make sense
it's obviously just a power grab and the
left is mocking us about this karen bass
who is a former communi communist maybe
not so former who is a democrat
congressman karen bass
is is laughing at us and she's saying
you know you don't see democrats
complaining about election integrity
republican larry elder has emerged as
the front runner on the gop side and
we've seen him already raise doubts
about this election's integrity even
before the results are known so how do
democrats respond to that these kinds of
claims or do you not do you just ignore
them all together
oh absolutely not we cannot ignore them
but i do think that we need to look at
it within the national context because
there is an undermining of the
confidence of the election process
nationally of course it started with uh
president trump uh what he did on
election day and so now we're
questioning the integrity of our
election system and this is so ironic
for somebody like me who focuses on
foreign affairs in congress we go around
the world talking about the strength of
our democracy and then people see all
around the country and around the world
us questioning the very institution so i
believe that what is behind it is the
fact that the republican party is using
this as a strategy you don't hear
democrats raising big questions about
the integrity of the election
so first of all
i guess karen bass is right on the
particular point right now you don't
hear
democrats complaining about the
integrity of our elections
five years ago
even less than five years ago that's all
you heard about remember russia stole
the election hillary is the legitimate
president of the united states trump is
a usurper remember remember that wasn't
that long ago
and it goes back even 20 years bush v
gore remember bush is an illegitimate
president gore really won the election
remember that all that stuff democrats
have often complained about election
integrity
then
in 2020 they got rid of all the election
integrity measures and they totally
upended the system in their favor to
make it easier for them to steal
elections and now they don't complain
about it well gee i wonder why yeah
because they they won they won the
election integrity game and they put the
rules in their favor so yeah now they
don't complain about it and this is so
embarrassing that americans lecture
people overseas on democracy but we
can't conduct our own
democracy yeah that is embarrassing i
wish you people would stop doing it
karen bass i wish you people would stop
destroying our system you'll notice uh
professor harvard professor adrian
vermeule made this point yesterday
the
when the democrats talk about our
democracy
the word democracy does not refer to
democracy in their minds
democracy is what happened in texas when
the people of texas decided not to
permit
other people to kill babies right
that that was a democratic process and
the left left hates that
what the left means when they say
democracy is liberalism and liberalism
and democracy are not the same thing
they're kind of related concepts but
they're different and when the people
vote against liberalism
they are we are told that that is the
undermining of democracy but it's not
it's the undermining of liberalism but
the undermining of liberalism is a very
good thing
and
as our
the other thing they often mean to say
our democracy is they're referring to
their oligarchy but even those two
concepts are related
as liberalism has grown in the governing
ideology democracy has shrunk
you do not have the right
for instance
actually abortion's a great example you
do not have the right
to make your own laws about abortion
liberalism has decided that abortion is
a sacrosanct
sacrament for that matter
and so you're not allowed to vote
they're going to pretend that it's in
the constitution when obviously it's not
and that's it now that's off the table
this is true increasingly of of many
areas of public policy there
are different rules for different people
we're seeing this not just
in the government
we're seeing this in the so-called
private sector though the private sector
seems pretty public to me we're seeing
this in big tech and facebook there's a
big report just came out in the wall
street journal
facebook says its rules apply to all
company documents reveal a secret elite
that is exempt so there's this program
known as x check that gives millions of
celebrities politicians and other
profile
users high profile users the privilege
to
get around the rules and this is not
some conspiracy theory this has been
revealed from internal facebook
documents that say for for certain
people they're not going to be held to
the same standard and that's that
now
sometimes i i
show different reactions to these sorts
of stories on a scale broke
woke and bespoke okay so the broke take
which is what the libs are
rattling on about right now is that this
is a good thing it's good that dr fauci
for instance
hypothetically could be exempted from
certain rules it's good that the left
gets to play by
easier rules than the right does okay
that's that's the broke take the woke
take the little bit a little bit smarter
take is that this is bad everyone should
be equal everyone should have to play
exactly on the same level playing field
on facebook as everyone else that's
definitely a better take than the left
should be given special privileges but i
i don't even think that quite gets it a
lot of conservatives are pushing that
that argument right now but i don't
think that even quite gets it
i would suggest the bespoke take
the the more perceptive one which is
hierarchies in politics are inevitable
there are this is a very conservative
understanding of human nature and
political communities there are going to
be hierarchies there is going to be an
elite there are people are going to be
in different positions and it's just the
way human nature works just the way
politics works
what is really bad about this
is that mark zuckerberg should not be
setting the political order
yes i grant you this is kind of my point
on free speech when when the the right
reacted to the left's manipulation of
our free speech
regime and said well you should be able
to say whatever you want and do whatever
you want i'm a free speech absolutist
and i just think that's
a silly argument it's a utopian argument
even that's not that's never been true
anywhere certainly not in america even
free speech has never meant you can say
whatever you want whenever you want to
say it every society has stan has
standards and taboos the question to me
that's more interesting is
who sets those standards who sets those
taboos what are they going to be what's
the same exact principle here who sets
the political hierarchy
who's who sets the way that the
privilege and status is doled out in
society that's going to be inevitable
that's going to happen but why is this
one billionaire oligarch in silicon
valley why is he the one doing it
we used to at least live in a
constitutional republic where where we
the people did that sort of thing where
our political system did that sort of
thing but now
these these elites
these oligarchs in silicon valley run
that political system because they
control speech
and that is a political act
and part of that is the result it's not
just the result of the left grabbing
power it's the result of the right
becoming obsessed with this idea of
privatization and government always bad
and politics always bad and corporations
good and so we've just given our
politics to the corporations now the
corporations run our politics and we
have even less of a say in it
that doesn't make very much sense to me
you've got to step in and reassert an
authentic political order you're seeing
this in ohio you're saying this in a
town in ohio
where the mayor of hudson
is showing up
and telling school board members
to resign or else be charged with kiddy
porn
over an assignment so i'll tell you
about the assignment before i play this
mayor's excellent
speech
there was an assignment that went out in
the school to students with writing
prompts that said say for instance write
a sex scene you wouldn't show your mom
this is to high school students rewrite
the sex scene from above into one that
you would let your mom read
describe a time when you wanted to
orgasm but couldn't
10 euphemisms for sex
write an x-rated disney scenario a room
full of people who want to sleep
together describe this describe the
first time you had sex this is high
schoolers
i don't i'm not a prude you know i
really i promise you i'm really not a
prude but this is creepy this is really
weird i don't think that this is the
only or best way to improve a student's
writing or
ability to think cognitive skills
i think it's really creepy and weird and
so does the mayor of this town and the
mayor showed up and said you know i
talked to a judge this might be kitty
porn you sickos need to resign or else
we're going to charge it members of the
board my name is craig shubert i'm the
mayor of this city
it has come to my attention
that your educators
are distributing essentially what is
child pornography
in the classroom
i've spoken to a judge this evening
she's already confirmed that
so i'm going to give you a simple choice
you either choose to resign from this
board of education
or you will be charged
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
i love this
this
there are going to be
libertarian or i'd really say libertine
types who say this is an encroachment on
academic freedom which is another
totally bogus concept and this is the
teachers should have every right and
students should learn about sex in the
classroom and this is wrong this is this
is
he's taking away their freedom no
what you're seeing here is is not
in a way i guess it's
taking away the freedom
or
licentiousness of these of these
educators to
push porn in the classroom
but it is asserting a higher freedom an
exalted freedom
a political freedom to decide how your
kids are going to be educated
i get those two kind of freedoms are
coming into conflict but the higher
freedom the freedom that is really in
keeping with the american political
order the
true understanding of liberty here is
that assertion of the political
freedom we all need to do that
we all need to do that at our own levels
we we have been enslaved
by
by people who want to arouse our basest
passions and our appetites and make us
mistake those for true liberty
and think that as long as we're getting
a steady stream of drugs and porn and
free government cheese from aoc and joe
biden and andrew yang
he was he was pushing the universal
basic income as long as we're just given
stuff to satisfy our appetites and to go
away and to stop bothering the elite
while they rule the world that then
we're really free we're not
we're not we're slaves we're no
different than those people who are
carrying aoc's preposterous dress
to the cheers of yes slay queen that's
that's what we are in this situation and
if we if we want to and this is where
you go back to the founding fathers if
you want to regain and reassert that
political freedom you've got to
discipline yourself you've got to limit
yourself you've got to limit what these
educators are putting in the classrooms
then and only then are you really going
to be free
we need to bring back consequences
okay we have been living in a dream
world for the past several decades that
is pushed not just by the left but by
the right as well where you can just do
whatever you want and not face any
consequences oh it's
you saw this notably with free trade yes
we're going to ship all our jobs
overseas and we're going to ship our
manufacturing overseas and we're going
to empower our geopolitical rival china
and but it's going to be only good
there's going to be no downside
whatsoever money money money it's going
to be really good for china it's going
to be really good for america and the
gdp is going to go up and there's going
to be no consequence this was the
utopian promise of the free traders and
it hasn't really worked out so now
because china has risen and because
china is now challenging american
hegemony on the world stage now all of a
sudden we're finally way too late
beginning to push back against this the
united states is announcing a new effort
today
with the united kingdom and
australia three of the nations in what's
called five eyes which is an
intelligence alliance that is going to
focus on
sharing advanced technologies in a not
so hidden effort to counter chinese
aggression
well
i'm glad that finally these developed
countries are going to push back against
china but that's a big change of policy
after decade upon decade of encouraging
china's rights permitting china into the
world trade organization what does china
do immediately starts violating its
agreements
promoting chinese manufacturing
promoting
chinese education and bringing chinese
students and sometimes spies to american
schools promoting china at the expense
of our own country and who who is one of
the leading voices in that stupid
campaign oh right the current president
joe biden last year 130 000 chinese were
studying in the united states
they're really good we're going to try
to keep some of them
i'm only joking i'm only joking
but they are
we cannot claim the same number of
americans in china but our 100 000
strong initiative will dramatically
increase the number of young americans
living and studying in china competition
is not bad
competition that's healthy is good
this is the reason why i have held the
view for so many years and continue to
hold the view
that a rising china is a positive
development
there is the line this this was from
about 10 or 11 years ago
there is the uh the rest of the speech
was bad
and typical backslapping joey they're
pretty smart
those kids look at my teeth i'm gonna
slap you on the back i'm joe biden but
that line at the end i am of the opinion
and i've for a long time been of the
opinion that a rising china is a
positive development and now
everybody with two brain cells to rub
together which i guess it does exclude a
number of people in our ruling class
recognizes that a rising china is a very
negative development it's very bad
in this
world
very very bad indeed so where is the
consequence
joe biden needs to be held to account
the people who encouraged the rising
china which they did
not just in the democratic party but in
the republican party too they need to be
held
to account and they probably won't be
even the people who openly collude with
the chinese are not going to be held to
account
general milley
general milly chairman of the joint
chiefs of staff was just caught in this
new report from the washington post
reporting on a bob woodward book
apparently
willing to go to china to give them
highly classified information in the
event of an american strike to undermine
the commander-in-chief and the u.s
president this is a huge deal this is
incredible insubordination this is
conspiracy to commit treason if you ask
me even lieutenant colonel vinman one of
the
most annoying trump critics and he's a
you know military man but extremely
left-wing even he came out and said
millie's got to resign for this
so millie was asked about it
and he gave a non-denial
a non-denial denial this came through
his spokesman he said the chairman of
the joint chiefs regularly communicates
with the chiefs of defense across the
world including with china and russia
these conversations remain vital to
improving mutual understanding of u.s
national security interests reducing
tensions providing clarity and avoiding
unintended consequences or conflict
meaning
yeah he did it
that's the right yeah he did it so what
what are you going to do about it
really
ugly stuff there should be an
investigation to my mind he should be
put on trial
he should be charged with a crime and
put on trial this is this is really bad
stuff i usually think
keep it calm it's all right let people
do their jobs i know don't throw our
presidential candidates in jail what
general milly did is really bad and he's
not even denying it
speaking of
speaking of what's going on overseas
speaking of america losing hegemony
around the world there is a report
coming out now that angela merkel who is
the chancellor of germany
she could become the new head of the eu
there's a big survey that came out
pitting her against the french president
emmanuel macron and it said who should
be the head of the eu and merkel is
leading the pack so
this just reminds me because we've been
talking about nor macdonald who who died
unexpected not unexpectedly to him he
was privately fighting cancer for nine
years but unexpectedly to all of his
fans and it reminded me really of a
great nor macdonald bit he gave on on
the last episode of david letterman's
show
when i heard that we were going to give
the eu possibly to germany i thought
that's pretty strange isn't it because
they tried to take over europe one time
and then we beat them and it was a world
war and then we tried to be
they tried to take over europe the
second time we beat them there was a
world war and now we're just going to
give them europa i don't know if you all
are history buffs but nor mcdonald i
think explains it well there is one
country that worries me though not iraq
not iran not north korea the only
country that really worries me is uh the
country of germany
i don't know if you guys are history
buffs or not but
in the early
part of the previous century germany
decided to go to war and uh who did they
go to war with
the world
[Music]
that had never been tried before
and uh so you figure that would take
about five seconds for the world to win
but uh
no it was actually close
[Music]
then about then about 30 years pass and
uh germany decides again to go to war
and again it chooses as its enemy the
world
this time they have that guy strangly
crankly that guy
i'm not even going to dignify him by
saying his name but i think you know
what i'm done
[Music]
but you'd think at that point the world
will go listen germany
here's the deal you don't get to be a
country no more
on encounter you keep attacking
the world
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
borah our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by nica geneva michael
knowles show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matt
wall show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you your
family our country not just politics but
culture faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show